hi delivery for Michael Scott here we go
okay this is great thank you my friend
she's perfect
Oh Dwight may have your chair please and
some singles if you will all right all
right
this has arms is that gonna be a set all
right sure I can sign for it oh thanks
when I was seven my mother hired a pony
and a cart to come to my house for all
the kids and I got a really bad rash
from the pony and all the kids got to
ride the pony and I had to go inside and
my mother was rubbing cream on me for
probably three hours and I never came
outside and by the time I got out the
pony was already in the truck and around
the corner so that was my worst birthday
this is where paper comes from any
questions so yeah you cut the paper and
diet and stuff no we don't actually cut
the paper that's a good question the
paper is sent to us cut and dyed from a
paper manufacturer and then we sell it
to a business for more than we paid for
it that's not fair no yes it is it's
well you need someone in the middle to
facilitate you just a middleman I'm not
just me why does it the somme will just
sell the paper directly to people you
were describing Office Depot and they're
kind of running us out of business
we have better service than they do
there's greed let's take a look at what
he's doing everybody this is Creed and
he is in charge of something that right
correct say hi to the kids hi kids
yeah
you ever seen a foot with four toes no
no would you cut it out what is your
problem here we're not gonna see we're
not gonna see the 4-toed creed okay you
know there's something interesting about
me that you might want to know I used to
be the star of a kids show true I did I
am totally serious there was a show
called fundle bundle and I was a star
it's true I can prove it I can prove it
watch this right can you come here a
second I would like you to go to my
mother's house in Dixon City and if
she's at the pool the back kitchen
window should be unlocked I want you to
boost yourself up all right go down to
the basement in the basement is a tape
labeled fundle bundle I want you to grab
it I want you to get my guitar right
okay once you get a tambourine do you
know how to play the tambourine I'm
already getting the pizzas from brunetti
so you know I know I will okay Thank You
Ryan
good attitude hottest in the office all
right now what kind of pizza do you like
I don't get why parents are always
complaining about how tough it is to
raise kids I joke around with them you
give them pizza you give them candy you
let them live their lives or adults for
God's sake I'm going to give you a
little blast from the past of Michael
Gary Scott when he was a child star and
a show that you might remember called
fundle bundle okay without further ado
Ryan that is miss Trudy can't tell from
her costume but she had an amazing body
okay you can stop yes that is Edward R
meow yes check Montgomery I don't know
check a nail with Chet dumper so I want
to be on TV
everybody please shut up please
so you don't miss it okay next Saturday
that's me what's your favorite subject
in school recess so tell me what do you
want to be when you grow up I want to be
married and have a hundred kids so I can
have a hundred friends and no one can
say no to being my friend
okay well nice talking with you Michael
back to you miss Trudy hi everyone it's
one of my favorite sworn there did you
get married no not oh I just never
happened
how do you have any kids
ah nope do you have a girlfriend I do
okay shut Montgomery cool that's even I
am okay all right okay so you didn't get
to be who you wanted to be I guess not
you know I have a load of work to do so
I am going to grab a slice of this
delish pizza and I'm gonna go do my work
bye
I'm not flying then no I don't want to
talk about it all right okay fine
what do you think of Andy because on
paper Andy and I should be best buds we
even have the same top 10 all-time
favorite movie list down to the number
anything yes ma'am
not all the time sometimes I'll say I
don't like something he says he doesn't
like it either right he'll always agree
with whatever you saying he did the same
thing with Josh and Stanford if he did
that with Josh he could be doing that
with me when I was five years old I had
these spider-man pajamas and one night
my mom was talking me in and she tried
to give me a raspberry on my tummy you
know and I tried to crawl away and what
happened was her eyes were closed and
she grabbed me and she kissed me on my
butt and it was just the worst so I know
what it's like to have your butt kissed
literally and it's it's terrible and it
better not be what Andy is doing
there she is
I swear Phyllis you are as beautiful as
the first day you started work at
dunder-mifflin thanks Michael that's
sweet same as when you said it outside
mmm
how you doing excited yes Mary
me too if you do vomit that is okay I
did do you want to talk about tonight
you know because I know you're probably
worried about pleasing Bob a lot of
pressure
did you break wind it's okay if you did
it's a very natural reaction it's your
wedding and you're nervous
that wasn't me okay um I'm sure that Bob
that is that is pungent
are you selling that hairstyle I mean
Michael no just kind of natural I just
need some time okay you might be
surprised to learn that I have only been
to one other wedding it's actually a
very cute story
my mom was marrying Jeff and they asked
me to be ring bearer and I was
understandably emotional and somehow my
pants became wet long story short Jeff's
dog ended up as a ring bearer and the
irony is that after the ceremony that
dog peed on everything and nobody said
boo you look at her and she's kind of
matronly today but back in high school I
swear her nickname was Easy Rider
now as for Bob Bob Vance okay that's not
guys Thanksgiving he works okay hold on
hold on
look look I didn't say anything
what tell us his dad upstaged me at the
ceremony and I think you owe me this
okay give me the microphone
okay
you